Now that we've got that quackery out of the way, there's one serious topic I
need to discuss, which is multiple inheritance. And that's the answer to the
question of whether a class can have more than one base class. The answer
depends on the programming language. In Python the answer is yes. Other
languages don't allow this. For example, Java only allows a single base for a
class and works out other mechanisms to solve some of the problems that we saw
with multiple inheritance. In Python a class can have multiple bass classes and
this is both very useful and potentially quite dangerous. So here's an example,
so remember what we did before. We had a Discerning Bear, which was a subclass
of Grizzly Bear and it overrode the eat method of bear to be discerning and not
eat humans named Dave. So what shall we do if we want both discerning Grizzly
Bears and Discerning Black Bears? Well, one solution would be to add a new
subclass that would be a Discerning Black Bear that would also override the ID
method and that would be a subclass of Black Bear. This seems like a bad thing.
We've got a lot of duplication and we've mixed up our notions of whether a
bear's discerning and whether it can climb or knock down trees. So here's what
we're going to do instead. We'll define a new Discerning Bear class, which is a
subclass of bear and overrides the eat method. Then we can create a Discerning
Grizzly Bear, which is a subclass of both a Grizzly Bear and a Discerning Bear.
That means it will inherit the knock down method from Grizzly Bear and the eat
method from Discerning Bear. And we could also define a Discerning Black Bear
class which would inherit the climb method from Black Bear and the eat method
from Discerning Bear. Here's what the code looks like, its the same discerning
bear class we had before except for we have changed the base class which was the
Grizzly Bear, now its just the bear. To define the discerning Grizzly Bear class
all we need to do is inherit from two base classes, the Discerning Bear and the
Grizzly Bear. We don't need to define any new attributes. We've got the
behaviors we need by combining those two. Similarly for the Discerning Black
Bear all we need to do is inherit from the Discerning Bear and the Black Bear
and we have everything we need. So this is pretty neat and can be very useful,
but also can be a little tricky. So now we're going to have a quiz.